hello everyone
welcome to yet another tutorial on
statistics by simply learn today
discuss a very important rule in
statistics that is empirical rule
before we move ahead if you haven't
already subscribed to our channel
hit that subscribe button to never miss
an update so let's discuss the agenda
for today's tutorial
we will start this tutorial by
discussing what is empirical rule and
we'll see the graphical representation
of the empirical rule
then we'll work on an example to
understand the empirical rule more
comprehensively
so let's move ahead
what is empirical rule
the empirical rule it is also known as
the 68 95 99.7 rule states that 68
percent of the data occurs within the
one standard deviation of the mean and
95 percent of the data occurs within the
two standard deviation of the mean
similarly
the three standard deviations covers
99.7 percent of the total data
suppose we have a bell-shaped
distribution with mean value of 50 and
standard deviation 5.
we want to answer the following
questions
since the mean is 50 one standard
deviation to the right will be 55 2
standard deviation will be 60 and 3
standard deviation will be 65
in a similar manner one standard
deviation from the left will be 45 2
standard deviation will be 40 and c
standard deviation will be 35.
since 50 represents the mean value all
the values below 50 will cover the 50 of
the total data
the value 40 and 60 are within two
standard deviations of the mean which
covers 95 percent of the total data
the value 50 and 55 represent exactly 34
percent of the total data and greater
than 55 represents 16 of the total data
consider the following example
the marks and signs of a group of
students follow a normal distribution
with a mean value of 70 and standard
deviation of 4.
we want to find a range around the mean
that includes 95 of the grade
so let's first note down the important
data we are given a mean value of 70 and
standard deviation of 4.
so from the previous slide we know that
the 95 percent of the data
means the two standard deviation on
either of the sides of the mean
will add and subtract the standard two
standard deviations that is 2 into 4
from 70 on the either side which will
give us the value of 62 and 78
respectively
this means that 95 of the total grades
lies between the mark 62 and 78.
so with this we have come to an end to
this tutorial
thank you all for watching this session
we hope you enjoyed it
if you have any questions feel free to
put them in the comment section of this
video thank you again and happy
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here